thank you and again thankfully on on
site both throughout the day now
we know we were thankful to have a job
we're thankful to be doing what we're
doing with thankful for the cassidy crew
that uh that we were able to hang with
every day
and we the main thing that we i think
just really demanded of everybody just
to give respect to everybody
i love that so i mean as long as
everyone played in that
sandbox it all was well but if we ever
got the point where somebody was not
playing in that sandbox
then one of us wouldn't right step up
you're not going to win this battle
right right right one of you is going to
stick up for the one of you is going to
take the initiative
i mean look i and i i hear you i mean i
did a short lived show for two years and
i remember
being the lead and a producer on it and
just saying hey
we're not here to make art we're here to
make fart let's uh let's have fun
let's laugh and that's how it was the
whole everybody in that crew
we had the best freaking time it was
never tense and that
it was a comedy it was funny i remember
like
like what was like season one i think we
had a producer
who was brought up to kind of run the
ship oh yeah
and it was from i think this moment that
we realized okay this is what the show
is going to be
we're going to all just have a good time
i'll never forget me and roday
you know the crew were there just like
laughing and having a good time and the
day's going it's starting to go so we
need to get work done but
we're getting it done and i'll never
forget he came and he was like all right
all right
all right guys enough enough let's let's
get to work let's get to work
i was like okay
you did it like that
yeah it was it was pretty fantastic it
was also like it was the only attempt
that the studio ever made
oh gosh and having like representation
on our set
and it was such a quick and easy lesson
that they learned of just like oh it's
not that
it's not that show um we're just gonna
have to roll with this
because it says that doesn't that's not
gonna work so
he was only he's only there for like
maybe six episodes or something
and they pulled him out and we never had
we never had a producer on set again
like no that's okay yeah
and then even if anybody like it wasn't
safe it was a director that
was an [ __ ] either myself or
oda somebody would just kind of give a
call say he add that person can't come
back because
and even if they treated us because
sometimes we wouldn't even hear that
for us we loved them and they would hear
later on
oh no you know they treated they treated
the
crew like like like an [ __ ] they
would they were addicted to the crew
they wouldn't come back we said no we
can't we can't
we can't do that we're not that's not
what we're doing over here did you get
on the call or
one of you or both of you or just sent
an email or was it yeah at the end of
each season it was basically like
uh who would you guys like who didn't
you like who should we bring back
and you know we were the ones that were
there nobody else was there
so they there's the power that you were
referring
there it is
you